c'est un rituel de passage qui fait
toujours du bruit
alors imaginons la même scène avec des
proviseurs dans le rôle du premier promo
des lycées généraux et techniques cette
année il y aurait les augustins à
pontarlier juste devant friands à
poligny le seul lycée public à se
classer dans le top 5
un club décidément très privé logis en
pergaud et 6e côté lycées pros le
lauréat c'est claude nicolas ledoux à
besançon talonné par sainte maria l'once
et ferdinand fillot de saint-amour
grande oubliée la haute saône ne place
qu'un seul lycée dans les deux top-10
allure mais tout comme le bac ce
classement n'a qu'une valeur relative
certes le taux de réussite au diplôme y
est pondéré par le nombre de mentions
d'élèves et le taux d'échec depuis la
seconde il n'empêche
et le rectorat est le premier à le dire
la comparaison objective est impossible
un peu comme un taux de réussite de 100
% au bac